PROFESSOR: This time we're
actually going to be able to
do a little work that I hope
will give you a good idea of
why it is that at least
low-density parity-check codes
work and even broader classes
of capacity-achieving codes.
But I think we're going to limit
ourselves to a week, so
that we can say something next
week about everything we've
been talking about as binary
codes for the power limited
additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
We've completely left aside
codes for the bandwidth
limited channel, where we're
going to have to talk about
non-binary codes of some kind.
So next week I'll give you a
very rushed overview of that
kind of code.
And it's my intention, by the
way, that last week, you'll
not be held responsible for on
the exams, so that we kind
have a nice, pleasant week
without worrying about whether
we're responsible
for it or not.
And the last homework set, I
will prepare a homework set on
the bandwidth limited
type codes.
On Wednesday, I'll hand it out,
but I won't expect you to
give it back.
It's good to do it.
I'll hand out solutions on the
final day of the exam.
OK, so any questions
about where we
are, what we're doing?
All right, let's get into it.
We've been building up
to this for a while.
First we did trellis
representations of block codes.
As a warm-up for codes on
graphs, we found that some of
the things we discovered about
trellises were important
particularly in the context
of the cut-set bound.
The cut-set bound says, where
you have a cut-set, the
complexity at that point must
be at least as great as that
of a trellis diagram which
divides the two parts of the
code into two halves,
and the past and
future in the same way.
And from that we concluded
that we're
going to need cycles.
Because we'd already proved
back in chapter 10 that
trellis complexity needed to go
up exponentially with block
length, at least for codes
that maintained a nonzero
relative minimum distance
as well as a
nonzero relative rate.
So we're going to need cycles
in our graph we think --
to get to capacity.
Chapter 12 was a fairly short
chapter introducing the
sum-product algorithm.
I believe that you don't
really understand the
sum-product algorithm till you
do it once, so that's on this
week's homework.
You will do it once for a very
simple case, and then I think
you'll understand it.
We developed the sum-product
algorithm for cycle-free
graphs, where it's a theorem
that the sum-product algorithm
does APP decoding for every
variable in any cycle-free
graph in a very systematic
and efficient way.
It's a finite and exact
algorithm in that case.
It takes a number of steps
approximately equal to
diameter of the graph.
And when it's finished you
have the exact APPs
everywhere.
OK, but we really want to have
a decoding algorithm for
graphs with cycles.
Having developed the sum-product
decoding
algorithm, we see that it has a
nice, simple update rule at
each computation node.
It's a local kind
of algorithm.
Why don't we just let her
rip, start it off
and see how it does?
And, in our case, we can make
that work by designing graphs
that have, in particular, very
large girths such that the
graph looks--
the term-of-art is locally
tree-like.
In the neighborhood of any node,
if you go out some fixed
diameter from that node, you
won't run into any repetition.
So locally the graph
looks like a tree.
And we're going to, ultimately,
be looking at
asymptotically long codes, so
we'll be able to make that
locally tree-like assumption
hold for as far
out as we need to.
Other disciplines are not
so fortunate as to
be able to do that.
OK, so in this chapter we're
finally going to get capacity
approaching codes.
I'm first just going to mention
a couple of classes of
codes, the most famous and
important ones, show you what
their graphs look like.
From that, you will know
everything up to schedule what
there sum-product decoding
algorithm should be.
I'll tell you what the
conventional schedules for
decoding these graphs
with cycles are.
And that'll be an
introduction.
And then we'll get into actual
analysis, in particular, for
low-density parity-check codes
which are, really, the
simplest of these codes
and therefore the
most amenable to analysis.
And we'll see that, under the
locally tree-like assumption,
we can do an exact analysis
first, on the
binary erasure channel.
Then I'll at least discuss
what's involved on more
general channels, where we can
do a fairly precise analysis.
So that's where we're
going in chapter 13.
Questions, comments?
OK, so let's talk about
low-density
parity-check codes.
These codes have a fascinating
history.
They were invented by Professor
Gallager in his
doctoral thesis in 1961.
He was a student
of Peter Elias.
What people were doing at MIT
then was trying to figure out
ways to actually build codes
that get to capacity.
At MIT the emphasis was on so
called probabilistic codes.
Namely ones that had sort of the
random-like elements that
Shannon basically prescribed.
People here were not
so interested in
the algebraic codes.
And Gallager basically had the
idea that if you take a code
-- you can describe it by
a generator matrix or
parity-check matrix.
If you make a sparse generator
matrix, that's not going to be
any good, a random, sparse
generator matrix, because a
sparse generator matrix will
naturally have some low-weight
code words in it.
If the rows are sparse,
then it will have
low, minimum distance.
But maybe if we make the
parity-check matrix sparse,
very few ones in the
parity-check matrix, we can
still get a code that's
quasi-random.
And therefore we can hope that
the codes, as they get along,
will come close to doing what
Shannon said random codes
should easily be able to do.
The amazing thing about
Shannon's proof is he showed
that you pick any code out of a
hat, and it's highly likely
to be good.
So, basically, Gallager was
trying to replicate that.
And he came up the idea of
sparse or low-density
parity-check matrices and was
able to prove quite a few
things about them.
That they couldn't quite get
to capacity the way he
formulated them, but that they
could get very close.
They had a threshold a little
bit below capacity.
He came up with the APP decoding
algorithm for them
which is probably the first
instance of the sum-product
algorithm in any literature,
certainly the first
that I'm aware of.
And he simulated them.
At that time, what
MIT had was--
over in Building 26 on the first
floor, where I think
there's a library now.
It sticks out into the
adjacent parking lot.
That room was full of IBM
equipment, 70, 90 computer.
And there were people
in white coats who
attended all that equipment.
And by running that computer
for hours, he was able to
simulate low-density
parity-check codes down to an
error probability of about
ten to the minus fourth.
And he showed that he could get
down to 10 to the minus
fourth, pretty close
to capacity.
I don't remember exactly how
close, but it was enough to be
convincing.
Actually, in 1962 there was a
little company form called
Codex Corporation.
It was what we would now
call a start-up.
Back then, there was no
tradition of start-ups.
And it was basically founded to
exploit Gallager's patents,
which he took out on low-density
parity-check
codes, and Jim Massey's patents
on threshold decoding,
which is an extremely simple
decoding technique that we
haven't even talked about,
very low complexity.
And I joined that company in
1965 when I finish my thesis.
And I was director of research
and advanced product planning.
And I can assure you that in
the 20 years that those
patents lived, we never
considered once using
Gallager's low-density
parity-check codes, because
they were obviously far too
complicated for the technology
of the '60s and '70s.
We didn't have rooms full of
computers to decode them.
And more generally, in the
community, they were pretty
completely forgotten about.
There's a key paper by Michael
Tanner in 1981
where he kind of--
that's the founding paper for
the field of codes on graphs.
he puts it all into a
codes-on-graphs context,
develops all the
basic results.
It's a great paper.
It too, was forgotten about.
And the whole thing was pretty
much forgotten about by us
until other people, outside the
community, rediscovered it
right after turbo codes
were invented.
Turbo codes were first
presented in 1993
at the ICC in Geneva.
They had actually been invented
some four or five
years before that by Claude
Berrou in France.
And nobody could believe how
good the performance was.
This guy is not even a
communications guy.
He must have made a three
dB mistake, didn't
divide by two somewhere.
He showed you could get within
about a dB of capacity with
two simple codes.
And we'll see that
in a second.
But, sure enough, people went
and verified that these codes
work the way he said they did.
And, all of a sudden, there's
an explosion of interest.
And low-density parity-check
codes were rediscovered by a
couple of people, notably David
MacKay who also was a
physicist like Berrou,
in England.
But he had an interest in
information theory, at least
he was trying to solve
the right problem.
And he had similar ideas to
what Gallager had had.
And he simulated them-- by now,
you can simulate these
codes on a desktop computer--
and found that they got within a
dB of capacity and so forth.
And so then we were off to the
races, and the whole paradigm
of coding changed.
But it certainly is an
embarrassment to those of us
who were faithfully in the
field for 30, 35 years.
Why didn't it occur to us that
by the '90s the technology was
far enough advanced that we
could go back and look at what
Gallager did and realize that
these were actually pretty
good codes and now
implementable?
So I think that's
a nice story.
It's kind of humbling to those
of us in the field.
On the other hand, we can say
that, jeez, Gallager did it
back in 1960.
What's the big deal
about turbo codes?
Depends what perspective
you take.
I never know whether I should
tell a lot of stories or not
so many stories in this class.
If you like more stories,
just ask.
Anyone have any questions
at this point?
All right, low-density
parity-check codes, Gallager
in 1961, forgotten until 1995,
rediscovered by David MacKay,
Niclas Wiberg, and others.
And this was what
they look like.
The basic idea is we have a
parity-check representation of
the code, a long code.
So the code is the set of all
y such that yht equals 0.
And that's standard.
And the idea now is that this
parity-check matrix should be
low density or sparse.
In fact, the number
of ones in it--
It's a matrix, so that you would
think a random matrix is
0s and ones.
m minus k by n matrix would
have a number of ones that
goes up as n squared.
As n becomes large, let's make
sure that the number of ones
only goes up linearly
with n, as the block
length n becomes large.
So sparse h means number
of ones linear with n.
And we'll see that implies that
the complexity of the
graph is linear with n.
The ones are going to
correspond to the
edges in the graph.
And we'll have a linear number
of edges, also a linear number
of nodes or vertices.
OK, in general, what does a
code like this look like?
We have y 0, y one through--
what does its graph look
like, I should say--
yn minus one.
And then, so we're going to
have n symbols, which in
normal graphs we write
as equals nodes.
Then over here we're going to
have n minus k, a lesser
number of constraints or checks,
which in our notation
we've been writing like this.
And we're going to have an edge
for each one in here.
You can easily see that every
one in the parity-check matrix
ensures that it says that one of
the symbols participates in
one of the checks.
And therefore, the number
of edges is equal to
the number of ones.
So this is equal number
of edges in graph.
Not counting these little half
edges out over here, again.
So there's some random
number of edges.
We won't have them got
to the same place.
But this also is only
linear with n, here.
And, in fact, let's choose
these edges.
These edges are like a telephone
switchboard.
It's just a giant plug board
where everything that goes out
here, you can consider
going into a socket.
So let's draw, for instance, for
a regular code, let's draw
the same number of
sockets going out
for each of the symbols.
Each symbol is going to
participate in the
same number of checks.
Each one is going to have the
same degree, so that's why, in
graph terms, it's regular.
And each one of these checks,
we're also going to say has
the same degree.
So this was basically
the way Gallager
constructed codes, regular.
We'll later see if there's an
advantage to making these
somewhat irregular, these
degree distributions.
But this is certainly
the simplest case.
All right, how do we make a
random parity-check code?
So that we're going to
specify n, n minus k.
We're going to specify
these degrees.
So that's not random.
But we'll connect the edges
through a big switch board
which is denoted by pi, which
stands for permutations.
This is basically just
a permutation.
We've got to have the same
number of sockets on this side
as on this side.
And this is a just a reordering
of these sockets.
That's what a telephone
switchboard does.
Or it's very often in the
literature called an
interleaver, but, probably,
permutation would've been a
better word.
All right, so one way of doing
it is just to take this edge
here, this socket here and, at
random, we have-- let's say,
e, for number of edges-- e
sockets over here and just
pick one of those sockets
at random.
Take the next one and take the
e minus one that are left and
connect that to one of the the
e minus one at random.
So this would give you one of
the e factorial permutations
of e objects.
And it'll give you one
of them equiprobably.
So we're basically talking
about an equiprobable
distribution over all possible
permutations of e elements.
All right, so we consider all
these are equally likely when
we come to our analysis.
This is why these codes are
called probabilistic.
We set up some elements of their
structure, but then let
others be chosen randomly.
Clearly it's not going to matter
for the complexity of
the decoding algorithm
how this is done.
It might have something to do
with the performance of the
decoding algorithm, but any
decoding algorithm is going to
work the same way.
It's just a matter of when you
send a message in here, where
does it come out here
or vice versa.
So it doesn't really
affect complexity.
Let's see, there has to be some
relation between the left
degree d lambda and the right
degree d rho here in order
that we have the same number
of edges on each side.
We have e equals n times
d lambda, if we
look at the left side.
But it's also equal to n minus
k times the degree on the
right side.
Again, I'm only counting the
internal degree here and
leaving aside the
external guy.
And this gives us the following
relationship that n
minus k over n is equal
d lambda over d rho.
Or, equivalently, with this is
one minus the rate of the
code, or we can write rate
equals one minus d
lambda over d rho.
So that by deciding what left
degree and what right degree
to have, we're basically
enforcing this relationship
which comes out as the
rate of the code.
For instance, the choice that
we're going to talk about
throughout is we're going to
take a left degree equal to
three, right degree equal
to six, as I drew it.
If you do that, then you're
going to get a code of
nominal rate 1/2.
It's only a nominal
rate because what
could happen here?
I'm basically choosing a random
parity-check matrix,
and there's nothing that ensures
that all the rows of
this parity-check matrix are
going to be independent.
So I could have fewer than n
minus k independent rows in
the matrix, which would actually
mean the rate would
be higher than my design
rate, my nominal rate.
In fact, you can ignore
this possibility.
It's very low probability even
if you choose it at random.
If it does happen, people are
going to forget about the
dependent row and pick another
independent row.
So I won't make a big deal.
We'll just call this the rate.
So if this were three here but
only four here, then we would
have a rate 1/4 code.
Well, we'd have to have 3/4s
as many checks as we have
symbols in order for everything
to add up.
So that's really,
basically, it.
Let's just specify the degrees
on the left, the degree on the
right, pick our permutation
at random, pick n or e.
We've designed a low-density
parity-check code.
And now, how do we
do we decode it?
Well, we use the sum-product
algorithm.
We've got a code on a graph.
In fact, it's a very simple
graph, notice it's
characteristic.
It's, again, just got equality
nodes and zero-sum nodes or
check nodes.
These are really the
simplest codes.
We could, more generally, have
more elaborate codes here.
That's one of the things Tanner
did in is 1981 paper.
But this is very simple.
All of our internal variables
are binary.
I, for one, thought that it
would be necessary to go
beyond binary internal variables
in order to get to
capacity but that proved
not to be the case.
Really, this structure is
all you need to get to
capacity it turns out.
Except for one thing,
you need to make
these degrees irregular.
And for the most part, you only
need to make the left
degrees irregular.
So we'll get far enough
to see why that is
going to do the trick.
But right now, I talked about
the decoding algorithm.
So the decoding algorithm is
pretty much what you would
think, I would hope.
Now that you've seen some
product decoding.
You receive something on each of
these lines, depending what
the channel is.
If it's an additive white
Gaussian noise channel, you
get a real number, received
vector that gives you some
intrinsic information about the
relative likelihoods of 0
and one on each of
these lines.
So each of these points, you get
an in going message based
on what you receive.
At a repetition node that
message is simply propagated,
if you look at the equations of
the sum-product algorithm.
Repetition nodes just propagate
what they receive at
one terminal on all the
output terminals.
All the d minus one terminals
are determined
by the by one terminal.
So we get the same thing going
as and output message.
This, very often, is drawn
as a Tanner graph.
In that case, all we have
here is symbols.
That's natural to just take the
likelihoods of the symbols
and send them out.
So we haven't done anything
more than that.
These messages all arrive here
as incoming messages from
various far and distant lands.
To find the outgoing message
say, on this line
here, what's our rule?
Our rule is to take the incoming
messages on all d
minus one of these nodes and
combine their likelihoods
according to which of these is
consistent with a 0 output
here, and which of these
is consistent with the
one going out here.
We get a bunch of weights
for 0, and a bunch
of weights for one.
We add them all up.
And that gives us now, a
re-computed likelihood.
A message consisting of
probability of 0 given what
we've seen so far, and
probability of one given what
we've seen so far.
But now it goes out.
Hopefully that's got some
improved information in it now
coming from all different parts
of the graph, extrinsic.
So this, eventually, will come
back somewhere say, here and
similarly on all the
other lines.
And now this will give you
additional information.
You combine these, and now what
you have coming out here
is a combination of what you had
coming in here, which was
originally a state of complete
ignorance, but now you combine
these you get more information
going out and so forth.
So you iterate.
You basically do a left side
iteration, then a right side
iteration, a left
side iteration,
a right side iteration.
Hopefully the quality of your
APP vectors is continually
increasing during this.
You're somehow incorporating
more and more information.
You're hopefully converging.
And so, you just keep going
back and forth.
And low-density parity-check
codes you can do this
typically 100 times,
200 times.
It's a very simple
calculation.
You can do it a lot.
So you can do that.
When do you stop?
A very popular stopping
rule is to stop as
soon as you've got--
If you made hard decisions
on the basis of all these
messages, that would give
you binary values.
And if all those binary values
check at all these places,
then that's a code word.
Or that's a trajectory that's
consistent with the code word.
Basically, everything that's
over here then has
to be a code word.
So whenever all the checks,
check just based on hard
decisions, you stop.
So if there's very little noise
to start with, this can
happen very quickly
and terminate the
calculation well short.
Or you have some maximum number
of iterations you're
going to allow yourself.
If you go 200 iterations, and
these things still don't
check, probably you would
say this, I've
detected a decoding error.
One characteristic of
low-density parity-check
codes, is they tend to have
good minimum distance.
They tend to have a minimum
distance that's sort of what
you would get in a random-like
code, which goes up linearly
with the block length.
So for a rate 1/2 of code of
length a 1,000, a random code
would have a minimum distance
of about 110.
And a low-density parity-check
code would typically have a
large, maybe not 110, but a
large minimum distance, unless
you were just unlucky.
So the probability of your
actually converging to an
incorrect code word is tiny.
You don't actually make
decoding errors.
All of your errors
are detectable.
Which is a nice systems
advantage some of the time for
low-density parity-check
codes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
possible that if you add one
variation [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Possible in principal
but extraordinarily
improbable.
And once you've converged to a
code word, basically, you've
got all of all the messages
lined up in the same way.
It's like a piece of iron ore
where you've got all of
magnets going in the
same direction.
What is there in that that's
going to cause them to flip?
There's no impetus for
any of these to--
They'll tend to get more and
more convinced that what
they're doing is right.
They'll reinforce each other.
So, as a practical matter, I
don't think you would ever--
The kind of landscape of these
codes is that there's large
areas of the parameters where
it doesn't tell you to go in
any particular direction.
And then there are deep wells
around code words.
So, typically, the decoding
algorithm is kind of wandering
around the desert here, but then
once it gets into a well,
it goes wrong boom, down to
the bottom of that well.
And once it's down here, it's
extremely unlikely that it'll
spontaneously work itself out
come back over here again.
Powerful basins of
attraction here.
Which is another reason why when
we design the code, we're
basically designing
this landscape.
And we can design it to--
when it starts to converge,
it really converges fast.
That's why some classes
of these codes are
called tornado codes.
They wander for a while, and
then when they get the idea,
then [WOOM], everything
checks very quickly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so you would compute the--
at each [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
calculate one of the so do you
calculate all of the messages
that go back from each
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] first and
then propagate then back--
PROFESSOR: Yes, correct.
I'm sorry.
We nominally calculate this one,
but at the same time, we
calculate every other one.
All e of them.
Each one of these is based
on the d rho minus one--
other inputs.
So it ignores the message
that's coming in on that
particular edge.
It uses all the other messages
to give and extrinsic
message going out.
Which you could combine back
here or here, there the same
thing, to give you your best
overall APP right now from
your right going in your
left going messages.
But you don't.
You now use this new
information in your
next round over here.
And the same thing
on this side.
You always compute one on the
basis of all of the others.
And the initialization is that
initially you have no
information coming this way.
You can represent that by an
APP vector that's 1/2, 1/2.
Probability of one is 1/2,
probability of 0 is 1/2.
Any other questions?
OK, so that's how it works.
And it works great.
And, as we'll see,
even with regular
codes you can get within--
additive white Gaussian noise
channel terms, you can get
within about a dB, a dB and
a half of capacity.
And merely by making these
degree distributions
irregular, this is how,
Sae-Young Chung got the
results that I showed, I think,
in chapter one, where
you get within 0.04 dB of white
Gaussian noise capacity
and that's it.
So we knew how to get to
capacity since 1961 almost, we
just didn't realize it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: With the LDPC regular
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
I missed--
AUDIENCE: With regular LDPC
you can still have
a certain gap or?
PROFESSOR: With regular LDPC
there's a threshold below
which the algorithm works,
above which the algorithm
doesn't work, as we'll
see shortly.
And the threshold
is not capacity.
It's somewhat below capacity.
By going to irregular you can
make that threshold as close
to capacity as you like.
You can never make it
equal to capacity.
All right, so let's talk
about turbo codes.
None of these ideas is very
difficult, which is, again,
humbling to those of us in the
community who failed to think
of them for 35 years.
And I really hope some historian
of science someday
does a nice job on culture, and
why some people were blind
to this and some people
saw it and so forth.
OK, so this is Berrou, Glavieux,
and Thitimajshima--
which I always have problems
spelling--
in 1993.
And their idea was pretty
simple too.
Their idea is based on two, rate
1/2, convolutional codes.
Let me use notation.
We have a certain u of
d, which is a set
of information bits.
And to make a rate 1/2
convolutional code, all I have
to do is pass that through
a certain g of d.
So I'm saying my generator
matrix for the convolutional
code is one and g of d.
That'll make a rate 1/2 code.
And this, I'm going to call that
a parity bit sequence,
occurring at the same rate as
the information bit sequence.
Easy enough, now, let me take
this same information bit
sequence, and let me put it
through a large permutation.
Which, again, I'll
represent by pi.
And I want you to think of this
as taking a 1,000 bit
block and mixing it all up
or something like that.
Actually, it's better to use
a so-called convolutional
permutation which is kind of
stream based, continuous, the
same way that convolutional
codes are.
All right, but it's basically
the same sequence permuted.
And let's also put that through
another g prime of d,
which, very often, is g of d.
So I'll just call that
g of d again.
And this is second parity
bit sequence.
And this all together, I will
call a rate 1/3 code.
For every one information
bit in, there are three
information bits out.
Same sense as convolutional.
All right, so the second
code, g prime of d is
one g prime of d.
And the interesting thing is,
these codes don't need to be
very complicated.
One thing they realized is
they do want this to be a
recursive code.
In other words, g of d should
look like n of d over d of d.
And one particular purpose of
that is that so a single
information bit will
ring forever.
The impulse response
to a single
information bit is infinite.
It takes at least two.
And you can prove to yourself
there's always some sequence
of length two in order to get
a finite number of parity
bits, a finite number
of nonzero
parity bits out of here.
And when those two bits are
permuted, they're going to
come up in totally different
places, so they are going to
look like two individual
information bits down here,
and therefore they're going to
ring for very long time.
The basic idea is, you don't
want an information sequence
which gives you a short code
word out of here and a short
code word out of here.
And making it recursive, have
feedback is what that means,
is what you need to do
to prevent that.
It also gives you better codes,
but I don't think
that's really why--
If you have g of d over n of
d, this is going to be
equivalent to the code we're
multiplying to the
non-recursive feedback
free code, which is d
of d, n of d, right?
We worked all that out.
It's equivalent to the code
where you multiply through by
the denominator.
And so you get the same code
with d of d, n of d, but you
don't want to do that, because
you are concerned here about
the input output relationship
between input bits and the
encoded bits.
And you want the information bit
sequence to come through
by itself, because it's
going to be reused.
You want the information bit
sequence to be in common
between these two.
That's going to be the length
when we decode these codes.
Basically, the messages
concerning the information bit
sequences is what's going
to go back and forth
between the two codes.
All right, do you get
the set up here?
I gave you a very different
perspective on it by drawing
the graph of this code.
I mean this is a graph
of the code, but
it's not one we want.
Let's draw the graph
of this code.
So turbo code graph, I'll draw
a normal graph, but again, if
you like to do it as a Tanner
style, be my guest.
All right, this first code--
Let me do this in two steps.
First of all, a rate
1/2 code graph.
So for one of these code,
what does it look like?
It's a trellis graph.
Which in the normal graph
picture is a very
simple chain graph.
It looks like this.
Here's the information
sequence.
Here are the states.
So these might be
simple codes.
These are typically four to 16
states, so two to four bits of
state information, not
very complicated.
So this is what it looks like.
We get one of these for each.
This is the branch constraint
for each unit of time.
This would be y0, y1, y2, y3,
you get two bits out for each
unit of time.
And this case, one of these is
actually the input at that
time, u0, u2.
Or we could adopt some other
indexing scheme.
It's systematic so, we think of
these as the inputs sort of
driving an output.
So maybe a better way
to do this is--
an alternative way of doing
it is like this.
But it's all the same
thing, right?
It's what you've already seen.
So I just want you to get used
to this way of writing the
graph of a trellis of a
rate 1/2 systematic
convolutional code.
Here are these systematic bits,
which are both inputs
and, ultimately, outputs
on to the channel.
And these are the parity
bits which are only
output onto the channel.
All right, and these
are the branch
constraints for each time.
And these are the state's
basis for each time.
So that I can always draw
that, that way.
All right, now up here, I
really have two of these
codes, possibly identical.
And what's the connection
between them?
The connection between them
is that they have the same
information, but in some
random order, some
pseudo-random interleaved
order.
So I draw a graph of that,
again, focus on the
interleaver.
Make it nice and big now.
There's always going to be a big
interleaver in the center
of all our charts.
This is always the random-like
element.
Now, let me draw my first
convolutional code over here.
I'm just going to tilt
this on its side.
I'm going to put the parity bits
on this side, the first
parity sequence.
So now this is running
in time either up to
down or down to up.
I don't care.
So forth, down to here,
et cetera, dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot--
And I'll put the information
bit over here.
And I'm going to do
it in this way.
The information bits
are, first of all,
used in this code.
So I have a little equality.
So these are going to be
in my information bits.
But then they're going to go
through this permutation and
also be used in another code
over on the right side.
Is this clear?
So this is everything
up to here.
I'm about to go into
the interleaver.
Stop me with questions
if anything is
mysterious about this.
OK, after some huge
permutation, they
come out over here.
And now these are information
bits that go into another
identical trellis--
or could be identical.
So we have a trellis over on
this side that's connected to
one parity bit and one
information bit.
It's another rate 1/2 trellis.
This is parity bits, these
are, again, info bits.
Same information bit sequence
but drastically permuted.
Is that clear?
So again this is the same idea
of a switchboard with sockets
we have the same number sockets
on the left side and
on the right side.
And we make a huge permutation
that ties one to the other.
It's only edges in here.
Notice there's no computation
that ever takes place in the
interleaver.
This is , again, it's purely
edges, purely sending messages
through here.
So the analogy of a switchboard
is a very good one.
Even though we don't have
switchboards anymore.
Maybe some of you don't even
know what a telephone
switchboard is?
It's a quaint but apt analogy.
All right, so this is the normal
graph of a turbo code.
I've drawn it to emphasize its
commonality with low-density
parity-check code.
The biggest element is this big
interleaver in here, and
that's key to the thing
working well.
All right, so how would we
apply the sum-product
algorithm to this code?
What would our decoding
schedule be?
In this case, when we observe
the channel, we get messages
in all these places.
So we get intrinsic information
coming in for all
the external symbols.
First step might be to
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's first
step, we can--
In the same way, this is just
a distribution node when
originally all else
is ignorance.
So these same messages just
propagate out here, and if we
like, we can get them
out over here.
All these are available too.
OK, somebody else.
What's the next step?
Somebody was just
about to say it.
Be bold, somebody.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The trellis
decoding--
PROFESSOR: Trellis
decoding, right.
If we forget about that side
and just look at what the
sum-product algorithm does over
here, we're doing the
sum-product algorithm on a
trellis, a BCJR algorithm.
So given all these messages,
we do our backward forward
algorithm, alphas and betas,
eventually epsilons, extrinsic
information coming out on
all nodes there, there,
there, and so forth.
And that requires going up and
down the whole trellis.
If this is a 1,000 bit block,
as it often is, or larger it
means going from top to bottom
through the whole block and
doing one sweep of a BCJR
algorithm through that block,
which will generate a
bunch of extrinsic
information over here.
Now, we have more over here.
We still got the same intrinsic
information coming
in here, but now we can take
this new extrinsic information
and combine it with this
intrinsic information and,
hopefully, get an improved,
higher quality information.
Because we've incorporated all
the information from all these
receive symbols on this side,
and we send that over here.
And if you think of it in signal
to noise ratio terms,
as some people do, you hopefully
have improved the
signal to noise ratio in your
information that's coming out.
It's as though you received
these bits over a higher
quality channel.
They tell you more about the
information bits then you got
just from looking at the raw
data from the channel.
That's basically where
turbo comes from.
You then do BCJR over here using
this improved intrinsic
information, of course,
the parity
information hasn't improved.
You might think of ways
to improve this too.
But this was the basic scheme.
It works just fine.
You come over here.
You then do a complete sweep
through a 1,000 bits or
whatever, and you develop
outgoing messages here.
Which again, let's hope we've
improved the signal-noise
ratio a little bit more, that
these are even more
informative about
the input bits.
And they come back, and now,
with this further improved
information, we can sweep
through here again.
That's where the turbo
comes from.
You keep recycling the
information left to right and
right to left.
And, hopefully, you
build up power.
You lower the signal-noise
ratio each time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and then you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the other side is kind of
[? encouraging. ?]
Now, why can't you, because on
this side, actually, the
equilibrium is just the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] version of
the other side.
Why would you do it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
carry out, and do it again?
PROFESSOR: So a good question.
You certainly could.
So after you've done it twice,
you basically processed all
the same things as this thing
does in one iteration, you
spent twice as much effort.
The question is, is now the
quality of your information
any better?
And I haven't done this myself,
but I suspect people
in the business did this, and
they found they didn't get
enough improvement to make
up for the additional
computation.
But that's an alternative that
you could reasonably try.
AUDIENCE: The reason I say that
is because if you do it
that way, that means for the
second decoding process of the
left side, the information
is very fresh.
Because it's sort of [? right ?]
information.
If you do this and this and
this, it looks like there is
enough propogation of the same
provision to itself.
PROFESSOR: There certainly is.
There are certainly cycles
in this graph.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, well, these
are great questions.
What I hope that you will get
from this class is that you
will be able to go back and
say, well why don't we try
doing it this way?
Whereas everybody else has just
been following what they
read in the literature, and it
says, to do it first here, and
then there, and then there.
Try it.
Maybe it's good.
You're suggesting that suppose
this guy it actually has poor
information.
He could actually make things
worse over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
also [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So then if this guy
just operated on the fresh
information.
It's a probabilistic thing
whether this would work better
on the average.
I don't know.
I suspect that, once upon a
time, all these things have
been tried.
But certainly, if you're in any
kind of new situation, new
channel, new code, you might
think to try it again.
It's a very reasonable
suggestion.
Because computation is not
free, there is a marked
difference in turbo decoding in
that you're spending a lot
more time decoding each side.
This PCJR algorithm is a lot
more complicated than just
executing-- well, it's gone
now-- but the sum-product
update rule for equals
or 0 sum node.
That's a very simple
operation.
On the other hand, it doesn't
get that much done.
You can think of this as doing
a lot of processing on this
information over here before
passing it back.
Then this does a lot of
processing before passing it
back again.
And so for turbo codes,
typically, they only do 10 or
20 iterations.
Whereas for low-density
parity-check codes, one does
hundreds of iterations, of
much simpler iterations.
But, in either case, you've got
to deal with the fact that
as you get up in the number of
iterations, you are getting to
the region where cycles begin
to have an effect, where you
are re-processing old
information as though it was
new, independent information.
This tends to make you
overconfident.
Once you get in the vicinity
of a decision or of a fixed
point, whether it's a decision
or not, it tends to lock you
into that fixed point.
Your processing, after a while,
just reinforces itself.
Now, another thing, turbo
codes in contrast to
low-density parity-check codes,
generally have terrible
minimum distance.
If you can work through the
algebra, and there's always
some weight 2 code word that
produces maybe eight things
out here and 10 out here.
So the total minimum distance is
only 20, no matter how long
the turbo code gets.
All right, so when I say
terrible, I don't mean two,
but I mean 20 or 30 could be a
number for minimum distance.
Certainly, this is called
parallel concatenation, where
you have these two codes in
parallel, and just pass
information bits back and
forth between them.
It's typical that you get poor
minimum distance which
eventually shows up
as an error floor.
In all these codes, when you
draw the performance curve, as
we always draw it, you tend to
get what's called a waterfall
region, where things behave
in a very steep
Gaussian like measure.
When you measure distance from
the capacity, you might be--
Oh, let's do this first,
assess an r norm.
So capacity is always at 0dB.
And this is probability
of error.
So this is your distance from
capacity, and this might be
1dB, or 3/10 dB, or something
very good.
But then, as you get down below,
some cases it could be
10 to the minus three or four,
some cases it could be 10 to
the minus seven.
So where it starts
is important.
Then this tends to flatten
out like that.
And this is simply what you
get from the union-bound
estimate for poor distance.
So, in this region, other things
hurt you worse than the
distance did.
If you are purely limited by
distance, then you would have
a performance like this.
There a very, tiny number of
minimum distance code words.
There may be only a few in 1,000
length block, so the
error coefficient
is very small.
That's why this is
way down here.
The interleaver tends to give
you a 1/n effect on the error
coefficient.
So this is way down here, and
it doesn't bother you in the
waterfall region,
but then at some
point it becomes dominant.
You can think of these as being
two types of curves.
This is the iterative
decoding curve.
This is simple maximum
likelihood of decoding when
you have minimum distance
of d with a small error
coefficient.
And so where this error floor
is an important issue for
turbo codes.
In some communications
applications really all you're
interested in is 10 to
the minus four, 10
to the minus five.
And then you really want to put
all of your emphasis on
the waterfall region and just
keep the error floor from
being not too bad.
So that would be a very good
application for turbo code.
But if, as some people think
they want, error probabilities
like 10 to the minus 12, or 10
to the minus 15, probably
turbo code is not going to
be your best candidate.
And it's not that you couldn't
create a code with better
minimum distance, but it's
going to get harder.
I don't know that much effort
has gone into this, because we
have low-density parity-check
codes for this other
application.
Any questions on turbo code?
That's about all I'm
going to say.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why not expurgate
the bad code words?
PROFESSOR: Expurgate
the bad code words.
Well, how exactly are you
going to do that?
AUDIENCE: Any malady report.
We disallow certain using
[? passes. ?]
PROFESSOR: So you're not going
to mess with the g of d, but
you're going to go through, you
going to find all the u of
d's that lead to low weight
sequences, and then you're
going to expurgate them.
Of course, it's a linear code,
so if there's a low weight
sequence in the neighborhood of
0, then there is going to
be a corresponding sequence in
the neighborhood of any of the
code words.
So you're going to have to
expurgate, somehow, around all
the code words.
I don't know how to do it.
AUDIENCE: You would
sacrifice rate.
PROFESSOR: You will
sacrifice rate?
Oh, one other thing
I should mention.
Very commonly in turbo codes,
they don't send
all of these bits.
They send fewer bits, which.
in effect, raises the rate.
But then, of course, makes
decoding harder, because you
don't get any received
information from the bits that
you don't send.
But there are various
philosophies of what's called
puncturing--
that I'm certainly
no expert on--
and it's possible that by
being very clever about
puncturing you could
do something
about minimum distance.
Shortening is where you hold
some of these bits to 0 and
don't send them.
Puncturing mean to let them go
free and don't send them.
So I don't know.
But I don't think this is a
very profitable way to go.
But it's certainly a reasonable
question to ask.
Any time that you get into a
minimum distance limited
situation, you should think
about, is there some way I can
just expurgate that small
fraction of code words in the
neighborhood of every
code word that have
that minimum distance.
This, as I said, is called
parallel concatenation.
Sorry, I didn't mean to cut off
questions about turbo codes.
I did say, I'm not going to
talk about them again.
They, of course, gotten a
lot of publicity, are
very popular initially.
This was a revolution
in coding.
Turbo codes got into all the
new standards and so forth.
Every communications company had
a small group simulating
turbo codes.
And so they got a tremendous
amount of momentum.
Low-density parity-check codes
really didn't get looked at
till a couple years later.
As you'll see, there's a lot
more analytical work you can
do a low-density parity-check
codes, so they're popular in
the academic community
for that reason.
But, in fact, it turned out that
the analysis allowed you
to do fine tuning of the
design of low-density
parity-check codes.
There are more knobs that you
can do, such that you really
can get closer to capacity with
low-density parity-check
codes than with turbo codes.
They have other differences in
characteristics, but, for both
of these reasons, there is
certainly a move now.
The low-density parity-check
codes seem to be the favored
ones in any new standards.
But we still have a lot of
existing standards, and people
who've already developed turbo
code chips and so forth who
have a vested interest
against moving.
Perhaps analog devices
is one like that.
So, although you can see the
trend is toward low-density
parity-check codes, there
are many industrial and
competitive factors and
inertia factors.
They'll both be around
for a long time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
turbo code they have a patent
you have to pay a royalty to
the company.
And with LDPC you
don't have to--
PROFESSOR: Yes, since this is
a theoretical class, but, of
course, issues like patents
are very important.
Berrou, Glavieux, and all
were working at ENST
Bretagne up in Brittany.
They were funded by
France Telecom.
France Telecom went out and
owns all the turbo code
patents and has decided
to enforce them.
Whereas Bob Gallager's
patents all--
We owned the ball.
We never made a dime.
They all duly expired
around 1980.
And no one needs to worry about
at least basic patents
on low-density parity-check
codes.
Of course, refinements can
always be patented.
So I don't know what the
situation is there.
And that often makes a big
difference as to what people
want to see standardized
and used in practice.
So, excellent point.
All right, well, we can come
back to this at any point.
Serial concatenation--
Here the idea is you, basically,
go through one
code, then you interleave,
and then you go
through another code.
This is the kind of setup that
I talked about back when we
talked about--
This could be a small block
code or convolutional code
that you do maximum likelihood
decoding on, need to do a
Viterbi algorithm.
And this could be a Reed-Solomon
code, and the
interleaver might be in there
for some kind of burst
protection or to decorrelate
any memory in
the channel out here.
So that's the context in which
concatenated codes were
originally invented.
That's the way they're used on
space channel for instance,
additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
But here we're talking about
the same block diagram, but
we're talking about much
simpler codes.
And again, the idea is to build
a big code using very
simple component codes, which is
what we did in low-density
parity-check codes.
That's a big code built up,
basically, out of 0 sum and
repetition codes.
Turbo code is a code built
up out of two simple
convolutional codes.
Here, I'm going to talk about
repeat-accumulate codes just
because they are so simple.
These were proposed by Divsalar
and McEliece really
for the purpose of trying to
find a simple enough turbo
code so you could prove some
theorems about it.
There are hardly any theorems
about turbo code.
It's all empirical.
We've got now some nice
analytical tools.
In particular, the exit chart,
which was a very nice,
empirical engineering chart like
Bode plots and Nyquist
plots, things like that.
It has a real engineering
flavor, but
it works very well.
The repeat accumulate code
is basically this.
We take input bits here.
We repeat n times.
So this, if you like, is an
n one n repetition code.
That's pretty simple.
We have a stream and a long
block, we would then permute
everything within the block.
And then this is a rate one or
one over one convolutional
code called an accumulator.
This is the code with transfer
function one over one plus d,
that means that y k plus
one is equal to y k
plus x k plus one.
So we have x coming in.
Here is one delay element.
Here's y k coming out.
And there is what
that looks like.
Xk plus one.
yk plus one.
So it's a very simple rate one
convolutional encoder with
feedback where I guess we
take this as the output.
That's called an accumulator
because, if you look at it,
what is yk doing?
You can show that yk plus one is
simply the sum up to k plus
one of all the xk prime.
k prime equals whatever it
starts at through k plus one
of all the xk prime.
It's nothing more than saying
than saying, g of d equals one
over one plus d, equals one plus
d plus e squared plus d.
The impulse response to
this is infinite.
And every past xk shows
up in every y.
This is just the sum
of all the xks.
But, of course, in the binary
field it's the mod 2 sum, so
it's only going to
be 0 and one.
Well, it's a little two-state,
rate one convolutional code.
About as simple as you can get
and obviously useless as a
standalone coded.
Rate one coders have
no redundancy.
They can't protect
against anything.
So that's the structure which
prior to turbo codes or
capacity approaching codes,
you would have said, what?
What are we trying to
achieve with this?
And the reason I talk about
them it that the codes
actually does pretty well.
All right, what's its
graph look like?
Over here we have input bits.
The input bits aren't actually
part of the output in this
case, so I won't draw
the dongle.
We just have an equals sign with
n call n equals three,
repetition from each.
Oh, what's the overall
rate of this code?
Here we have a rate
one over n code.
We don't do anything to the rate
here, so the overall rate
is one over n.
So let's take a rate 1/3.
So the graph, dot, dot, dot,
looks something like this.
And then, as always,
this element.
We take these bits in.
We permute them in some sort
of random permutation.
And then over here,
what do we have?
Well, we have a trellis again.
In this case, I can draw the
trellis very explicitly.
If we consider this to be the
information bit, and this to
be the previous state
bit, so this is yk.
And here's--
We're considering the y's to be
the output, so this is xk.
I think it works either way.
Let's call this x k plus one
plus y k equals y k plus one.
So this enforces
the constraint.
This is really the branch.
This is just to propagate
the y k and
present them as outputs.
So this little two state
code, here's the state.
The state is also the output.
The state is what's in here.
And this is what it's
trellis looks like.
That's the way this looks.
Of course, again, we need an
equal number of sockets on
this side and on this side.
So how would you decode
this code now?
What do we see initially?
We initially get received
data, measured intrinsic
information, for each of the
bits that we actually send
over the channel.
And what's our next step?
Trellis?
Yeah.
We do the sum-product algorithm
on this trellis.
So we just do BCJR ignoring the
fact that it's rate one.
That doesn't matter.
And so we will get some
information for each of these
guys that we compute from the
forward backward algorithm.
We'll ultimately get messages
going in this direction.
Which come over here when
we get them all.
And again, from these two
messages, we can compute an
output message here, from these
two, compute one there,
from these two, compute
one there.
So we combine and re-propagate
all these messages.
And that gives us new
information over here.
And now, based on that,
we can do BCJR again.
So again, it's this left right
sort of alternation, one side,
other side which, eventually,
spreads out the data through
the whole block.
We can use all the received data
in a block to decode all
the data in the block.
Now does this work as well as
either of the two previous
ones I put up, low-density
parity-check or turbo?
Not quite, but it works
amazingly well.
This is the moral here.
That even this incredibly
simple code, where
nothing is going on--
Again, all we have is binary
state variables.
We have equals and 0 sum
nodes, that's it.
It's made out of the simplest
possible elements.
Even this code can get
within a dB or
two of channel capacity.
And I'm old enough to know that
in 1993, we would have
thought that was a miracle.
So if this had been the first
code proposed at the ICC in
Geneva in 1993, and people had
said, we can get a dB and a
half from capacity, everyone
would have said, totally
unbelievable until they went
home and simulated it.
So I put this up just to
illustrate the power of these
ideas, and where
they come from.
Of course, this idea of using
the permutation as your
pseudo-random element so that
you, from very simple
components, you get the effect
of a large pseudo-random code,
could be a block length, a
1,000, 10,000, what have you,
this is absolutely key.
And this, basically, is what
Gallager had when he said, if
I just use my parity-check
matrix at random, even if it
is sparse, it's going to give me
a random-like, which means
a pretty good, code, because
that's the intuition I get
from Shannon and Elias.
That's the important part of
the code construction, but
then the decoding part of the
power is the sum-product
algorithm used in an
iterative way.
The idea that you can simply let
this algorithm run, and,
if the code is properly
designed, it will eventually
integrate all the information
over the block and converge to
some fixed point.
Although, even for such a simple
code as this, for this
code McEliece and his students
have a few theorems and can
say something about the
convergence behavior, and what
it's actually going to do.
Even for this code, they can't
get anything very definitive,
I would say.
So to me, the more important
thing about--
these are called RA codes--
is that incredibly simple
codes can do better than
concatenation of a 1,000 byte
Reed-Solomon code over g f of
two to the 10 with a two to the
14 state Viterbi decoder.
That doesn't do as well as this
crummy little thing does.
So that's good to know.
Any questions?
Well, it's a good
stopping place.
So next time, now, if you kind
of have an impressionistic
idea of how we do these codes.
Next time, I'm going to
analyze low-density
parity-check codes over the
binary erasure channel, where
you can do exact analysis, at
least in the asymptotic case.
And that will show very clearly
how it is that these
codes actually work.
It's a good model for all
the codes in general.
I guess that means that
you can't do a lot of
the homework again.
So for Wednesday, what
should we do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on Friday then?
PROFESSOR: Friday or Monday?
Monday seems to be popular.
So for Wednesday, just do--
There's one problem left over
from problem set eight.
And that's kind of a grungy
problem but worthwhile doing.
Try to do the sum-product
algorithm at least once.
So just do that for Wednesday,
and then for next Monday, a
week from today, problem set
nine other than that.
I'll see you Wednesday.